ryan
is with us ryan's in sacramento hey ryan
welcome to the ship
hey christy hey dave first time listener
thanks for having me
what's going on so um
i i think i kind of already know the
answer to this
but i kind of wanted to know the timing
on this um
so a little bit about me i'm 25 i didn't
have any debt
at all i love that life having no debt i
met my girlfriend
and she brought along with her a 11 000
student loan debt on top of that um
we had to get a new car so for her
and we are expecting a baby so we wanted
to get something safe
so that's at about fifteen thousand for
a total of about twenty six thousand
in debt now i know that i want to pay
off the student loan as soon as i can
wait a minute stop a second i don't i'm
going to i stop stop i'm confused
it says on my screen my wife's student
loan is this your girlfriend or your
wife
she's my girlfriend but i we have a baby
together
it's a yes or no answer yeah you're
either you're either married or you
aren't
you're not married is that what you're
saying no when are you getting
when are you getting married um
she wants to finish school first just
one financial aid reason
why um financial aid reasons
okay you have a baby a car loan and a
student loan and you can't pay any of it
because you're not married to her
i i pay the student i pay the car loan
though i mean the
yes i guess but i mean
for you know just for the sake of okay
let me try to let me try to help again
you said you're how old
25 okay i have a son
that is 28. if he sat down with me and
said dad what do i do in this situation
okay here's what i would tell him
you have a baby you are playing house
you're acting like you're married and
you are taking tons
of legal and relational risk
that you don't need to take by not being
married
you are up a creek financially
and legally
if things go sideways here okay
let me help you with this whose name is
the car in
both of ours okay if something happens
to your wife you now own a car with her
mother
because you're not married you have no
rights to the other half of the car
you're in a partnership legally speaking
do you understand
yes okay every dollar you guys try to
save everything you try to act like
you're playing house
does not work legally does not work
relationally
and you've set yourself up into a mess
now you can do whatever you want to do
young man
but you call this show and ask us okay
so what i will tell you as the old fart
here
representing the olfart contingent is if
i woke up in your shoes i would get
married tomorrow
and then we can ask the question how do
we get out of this
debt mess that my wife is in
of 11 000 worth of student loan and a
car we bought that we can't afford
now what do you make a year uh i'm a
life insurance agent so
it varies per month what do you make a
year about
upwards of a hundred thousand excellent
100 000.
excellent what does she make she's
full-time student
uh part uh student and she works so
short she's
probably about 25. okay so with 125 000
a year i think you guys can figure out a
way to pay for her school if you
lose any rights you have for her acting
like poor people
when she's not in order to get poor
people money for college
okay student aid she's not due for
student aid she lives 125
000 household income
all right and so you guys are good
months though dave well good morning
headed up in a year you got a year's
worth of income or don't you i mean i
ask you what you made so
listen you do whatever you want to do
sir that's what you're gonna do
uh and you should be able to do that
you're a grown person that's fine
but if if you were my s my own son
sitting at coffee with me that's what i
would tell you because
here's what we know we know there is a
marital lift
to your career people who are married
have better
incomes than people who aren't married
people who are married have much better
incomes than those that are shacked up
and not married
there's that this is statistical data
that's out there dude
it's all over the place it's called the
marriage lift look it up
okay they live longer i have no idea why
too afraid to die i don't know why why
do we people that are
wait why are those of us that are
married live longer i don't know i don't
know but
i will say there's a direct correlation
between strong
social connections and longevity and the
opposite is also true people that don't
have strong social connections i imagine
marriage being a piece of that
uh die sooner no there's there's for
your mental health for your overall
psychological health there's a direct
correlation
and so all of this for her to get
financial aid
when he's when they're making 125
household income so what i would tell
you to do is i get married this weekend
you do what you want to do this if i
woke up in your shoes knowing what i
know i'm from the old fart contingent
and i'm president of the club
and so you know if what would i do if i
woke up this today
knowing what in your shoes knowing what
i know now having lived life and done a
whole bunch of crap wrong
i get married tomorrow and then i would
get about the business of me and my wife
and my baby
and my 125 000 income completing her
degree paying off these two stupid loans
as soon as possible
and moving on with your life you have a
good life you're trying to trick the
system sir
and you don't get to trick the system
the system meaning how life works
you don't it's not an option you know
the things that i see people do a lot of
times dave and i've definitely been
guilty of this before is
i think one of the things i heard in his
question too and maybe i'm just giving
him too much of the benefit of the doubt
but one of the things i heard in his
question is
it sometimes i feel like when s when the
situation changes
when the variables change we still hold
our feet to the fire of this was our
original plan well the whole plan has
changed we need to adapt to the new plan
so in your example it's like
well she was used to getting this
financial aid and so it's like well now
this is different we have a baby we're
in a relationship we want to get married
just like well that changes
the scenario it changes your plans it
changes your
actions that you take but some people
don't some people are like well i was
planning on doing x y z and then this
happened and i'm still trying to do
exercise it's like no the plan
changes when the situation changes when
the variables change you need to
reassess what you're doing and if that's
still right
and i think that's part of what you're
saying here because we're in a new
situation the financial aid is not a
variable here to consider when you're
talking about
the other more important variables at
play well when you
if even if it is you said there's
financial aid on one side of the page
you say what would happen if we didn't
get the financial aid but we had all
these other benefits
right the other benefits financially
mathematically
what i'm saying yes data right right are
going to
outweigh what you get it's just not
worth it it's not worth it and so and by
the way you've already made all these
decisions
you have a baby right you're shacked up
i mean you're already playing house
it's not like the decisions are going to
you know and so
you're just missing out on all the
benefits and i can't advise you
to pay off her student loan because if
something happens
it doesn't benefit you and your child
if something happens to her and you know
and by the way i've been doing this 30
years
something happens sometimes and it's not
always a
beautiful wonderful end to the story or
at least the next chapter is not always
beautiful and wonderful
and for goodness sakes you want to be
doing this stuff in the right order and
take care of business man
but you do what you want to do that's of
course always your option
but you cannot expect ever to get
anything except our best
love when you call here and that's us
loving you enough to tell you what we
think is going to give you the most
prosperity
and have the best life and so sometimes
people don't think it's love